hello everyone if you've been here all
day thanks for sticking around till the
end if you're just joining us welcome to
CNN second annual virtual symposium
advances in drug discovery and
development I'm Lauren wolf the head of
the science and tech group here at
chemical and engineering news and I'm
pleased to introduce our next speaker
Jeff Blaney he's the director of
computational chemistry and chemical
maddox at Genentech before joining
Genentech Jeff was well Jeff was busy he
was an executive at sgx pharmaceuticals
metaphoric DuPont pharmaceuticals and
chyron just to name a few and before
that Jack obtained a PhD in
pharmaceutical chemistry from UCSF he's
got many years of experience and
industrial drug discovery research
focusing on structure based design
high-throughput docking combinatorial
library design and chemical informatics
and in just a moment Jeff will be
presenting his talk entitled enabling
the best structure based design engine a
human expert sounds pretty intriguing to
me I'll be back to moderate a Q&A
session immediately after Jeff's
presentation please feel free to ask
questions any time just click the Q&A
button in the bottom left corner of your
screen and if you need any technical
assistance during the presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of your screen a few notes
and then I promise I'm done please note
that CNN does not endorse any products
with any company products or services
that may be mentioned in this
presentation and finally and most
importantly this talk will be archived
and available on demand at the
conference website for three months
after the live broadcast that's until
December 16 2015 and now I'm delighted
to hand it over to Jeff
Thanks hi everybody so I'm going to give
you a quick tour of how we have combined
invention all of one and two dimensional
chemical informatics tools with 3d tools
to bring structure based design
capability not just to copy deschanel
chemists but to all our medicinal
chemists crystallographers other
scientists on our big and it is for any
project teams part of the background for
this is starting fall around 2000 you
have been to fly structural their
high-throughput structural biology
photography really happened I don't sgx
in 2002 and got to see the one most
powerful platforms for doing that I've
been at Genentech since late two
thousand seven and here and in many
other places it's now pretty common for
the majority of our small molecule
project teams to have a pretty rapid
access to coke crystal structures which
means at any given time in a project we
might have dozens to in several cases
several hundred Co crystal structures
and that meant the challenge then of how
you navigate all of that and make them
easily accessible for design hypothesis
testing a big part of that then bring
all the other data to that and then
bridging these 2d and 3d Lords so we we
started their realizing we wanted to
connect a bunch of conventional tools
docking we use mostly proposed
predictions so predicting how a small
molecule would be likely to bind into
the site not so much for virtual
screening for virtual screening and
finding additional analogues to known
active compounds one of our favorite
tools there was rocks which we
supplanted with the fast rocks GPU
accelerated version several years ago so
that really does provide interactive
shape feature searching pretty
sophisticated confident
national analysis tools we're big fans
of the drastically improved database and
search tools from the Cambridge database
how the bad group is produced over the
years and integrated that with some of
our tools I guess and as a side I'd
mentioned something there that I think
it's a conceptual change in the last
decade or so which is that small
molecule crystal structures in the
Congress database' really can be
relevant for structured based design not
in predicting a receptor about
confirmation but in giving you a really
valuable database of what the preferred
torsion angles and distributions of
torrents are so that's how we've
integrated that the folks at chemical
computing group with mo done a nice job
of cooking that into their tools as well
our approach to structured based design
and ligand based design for that matter
is a hypothesis driven we're big on
calculated physical chemical properties
which range from PKA too long p to lofi
variety of other properties we've also
invested heavily in machine learning
approaches for i'd say more classifying
in vitro and in some cases in vivo dmpk
I'll talk a little bit more about that
layer and then finally we want to stuff
all that stuff into software that makes
it easy for non data specialist mean
medicinal chemists and another
scientists actually integrate all those
data to help make decisions in this sort
of complicated multi-parameter
optimization space that we live in on
the small molecule world right so one of
those was minimizing the amount of
effort that a non-specialist needs to do
to interpret protein coat crystal
structures so all of this stuff is
scripted in a common infrastructure but
it's customized for each one of our
projects teams which are further
suspicious if a kinase or nuclear
hormone receptor or whatever the target
is
no set sessions update dynamically as
new crystal structures get deposited
that also includes structures that might
involve an off-target that we're
interested in for selectivity in some
cases there might be some personal
graphic surrogates maybe a chimeric
protein those all get included in a
project specific session in Pinal or mon
one of the tricks there of course
crystal structures particularly those
that come from the protein data bank if
we use those don't necessarily have
correct connectivity for small molecules
within our internal structures we do
better there and the main trick we use
for that is represent the small molecule
connectivity based on the way they're
registered in the corporate registration
system of course that might mean the
photographer is not quite right as
tautomers of course could change on
binding those get updated manually based
on visual inspection we haven't filled
automated tools for that for each
protein class for example a kinase we
will choose a reference kinase and then
orient all the other members in that
particular project to that so that they
are consistently aligned and oriented
I'll show you in a few more slides how
we group them and make them easy to find
particular crystal structures by
substitution pattern by ligand family by
conformational class of the protein and
so on in the last couple of years we
became interested in some of the new
tools for trying to assess the third
line of stability of water such as short
hairs water map urbanized schmap a tool
that a similar goal that very different
implementation from desert scientific
all-pro ases we also annotate all these
structures with color coding assault and
accessible surface I'll mention in a
moment
I highly recommend that salt and
accessible surface rather another views
when something we'd finally we got in
place for all of our project teams
recently the slides so soon that it's
finally done is to make it really easy
for non crystallographer turn on
computational chemist to view electron
density maps in that modeling session
right so how do we classify all these
data the graphic there is a PI bowl and
for those of you that have used it will
not on the right hand side is with many
other viewers you can eat each row shows
a particular model in this case of coke
crystal structure each one of those are
tagged by the name of a chemical class
you can see that in that table on the
upper left each one of those are
definitions that are maintained in a
project specific way usually by the
computational chemist on that team we
will assign tags that are that for the
favorite names for a chemical family but
that project team reviews you can see
that those are associated with smarts
those of you who are computational
chemist or chem informatics people will
know about that for the rest of you
smarts is a very powerful language that
makes it very easy to specify a
substructure so that we can easily
identify what would the core of imatinib
be or adenosine or purine and and so on
those are dynamically a thought a fine
so that all the ligands that fall in
that particular class that map that
financial substructure featured get
recognized and group that way we can
also group them based on protein
conformational class for example kinases
of dfv ndf tree out this is all to make
navigating a session that could have
several hundred code crystal structures
much easier so this one zoomed in a
little bit we've also as part of this
can project session have pre computed
what if i'm aware called scenes you can
do a full on things and other software
this initial one is just a drain
Richardson style protein ribbon diagram
those are great for getting sort of a
conceptual view but if you really want
to zoom in and get involved and design
trying to interpret SAR then we'll zoom
in on the binding site also want to
mention on up to the right you can see
that we have a reference structure
always at the top that's what
everybody's aligned to know these other
objects we call multi-state optics those
are in this case different
representations of all of the ligands
there might be a couple hundred ligands
in here because the way time old setup
we mimic something similar in MO if I
were to select that first item exactly
the second one they're called all-league
I can then use the down arrow on my
keyboard or the down arrow on the primal
user interface to skip from one leg into
the next and quickly browse through all
of them and that gives me a really easy
way to look through a whole session
maybe find out if there's a group in a
particular pocket as we go farther down
where you see that set that says main
target and other targets in this
particular case the main target would be
able other targets would be related
kinases that maybe you would want to
include for selectivity reasons so this
is what a more detailed active site view
would look like now in this case I've
expanded one of the particular able code
crystal structures you can see we're
showing a solvent accessible surface
most graphics programs today can display
this in MOA 12 interaction surface
primal Falls it sold an accessible
different programs call it different
things the point is that if you look at
that surface you see the surface is
available just to the stick model that
ligand it's easier to visualize if you
use a lot Connolly molecular surface
they tend to be prettier they make nice
journal covers but most of us have a
hard time visualizing
the complete surface of the ligand if it
would be necessary to fill that larger
volume of a tomboy style circuit that's
why we recommend this one it's tends to
be easier to see small crevices nooks
and crannies and pockets you should
think about filling the bottom of the
side because a literature reference from
a few years ago this was a really nice
paper i highly recommend to
collaboration between baird kuhn and
others of roche basel with our neil
taylor it does of scientific and they
came up with essentially a series of
expert rules based on Alice's of the
protein data bank and Cambridge database
for what are preferred interactions from
a geometric point of view those are all
described in that paper those are
available through software called Oasis
we've used that as part of the
infrastructure for building these
structure based design sessions and you
can see those different color coded
dashed lines in there each one of those
is a different kind of a contact from a
hydrogen bond giving it a maybe an edge
to face an NH PI interaction van der
Waals collagen bond the system is pretty
smart and do a pretty good job of
picking up things like aromatic CH
hydrogen bonds and we'll also flag
things you'll notice there's a in a
center of the screening a red dashed
line that it thinks is an unfavorable
contact occasionally we'll see that
that's a misinterpretation of electron
density but once in a while it really
does appear to be something that would
be suboptimal it's suggested design
opportunity for how to improve it well
this is the view we recommend for
everybody to start with and thinking how
they start analyzing that structure
where there's pockets that may open and
close as they can easily move through
multiple crystal structures they can
begin to assess where the flexibility in
the protein is right finals are great
visualization system
pretty Falls pretty short for molecular
editing and designing analogs and for
that we move into mo Mo's become a
really good visualization tool also and
the preferred tool that we use for
molecular design by now we've talked
actually all of the medicinal chemist
out of uses and well the expert it is
we've integrated the same type of
visualization features i showed you from
time olinda here i guess i should also
emphasize a concept here it's all
designed by analogy to known active
molecules we're really not attempting de
novo design from scratch so this kind of
reference based design would be simple
and logging it could be a core scaffold
hop it could be making a hybrid from two
or three multiple molecules that are
overlapped so the Roche colleagues at
what used to be the Nutley and Palo Alto
sites and Basel sites did a lot of work
optimizing to the workflow for these
menus while we anticipated that
eventually also a pretty good
collaboration with the folks at ccg to
really come up with an optimized
workflow for chemist so we're not
worrying about tools like homology
modeling or because more complicated
work flows between community focused on
what's the process for editing a
molecule doing a reasonably good job of
energy minimizing it just to make sure
that you're in a good local minimum
we're not attempting here to predict
potency by qsar or fe p and NP BSA or
any other methods just assess is that
small molecule in a good local minimum
again one of the i think the other
conceptual changes that are about by the
increasing number of culture commercial
structures in the protein data bank and
also analyzing structures in the CSD is
the observation that strange small
molecules bound to proteins are an
exceedingly
rare event there's quite a bit of
literature on it I'd argue most of its
wrong due to misinterpretation work for
refinement of electron density maps will
see there's some more recent literature
sorry I've not cited them hear from
people at the csv open a few other
groups have published on that we analyze
those structures will find that the
quality of the ligand energies is
assessed by if you're not an issue an
epidemic motor mechanics indicates that
very little strain energy if any left
over the way conceptually I think about
it and like it to each other's small
molecule has very few degrees of freedom
to dissipate any strain of the fits not
like an eel into a binding site protein
has thousands collected very small
motions are going to be within the noise
of what even a high resolution crystal
structure can see but twisting a small
molecule torch and even something that
many chemists might think is relatively
flexible for example like a butyl chain
or an effort group task the family was
actually have pretty significant
consequences energetically which is why
you rarely saw them outside of it for
food range so here you'll see a
Genentech menu down to the right-hand
side that's a custom menu that we built
right into the mo menu that includes in
it for our calculator physical
properties conformational analysis tools
that are not available in MO some
including a approach that Alberto govan
air group is developed for calculating
the strain of a small molecule access to
docking tools other than the doctor and
mo fast rocks remote open I which is GPU
accelerated very very fast shape feature
search tool that we use a lot mostly for
suggesting new meta logs we use that for
hybrid design finding new cores they god
I'm not going to fun to tell you about
that as a tool
internally that is for taking a molecule
that you've designed registering it into
a database that we maintain it separate
from the corporate registry of virtual
molecules that are proposed on a project
team to be considered for synthesis I
should also mention behind the scenes
here all this is done with pretty
lightweight tools with web services and
things we look for in any of the
software systems that they all are easy
to integrate we try to minimize the
amount of custom software we build by
working with software systems that are
easy for us to connect your next slide
right so there's been a lot of work done
here inspired by work that some of the
people here I think first sovereign
flies or cellular to go on building
machine learning models that can
classify key dmpk experimental measures
that we rely on so here are our dmpk
Group routinely does in vitro clearance
measurements and liver microsomes and
pata sites of five different species we
measure plasma protein binding come
ability a netflix time dependent in
addition of a variety of cytochromes and
also try to build models correlating in
vivo parents with in vitro measured
clearance that's described in that
reference at the bottom of the slide I'm
not enough time to describe about how
the machine learning models were built
that's also mentioned in that paper I
will summarize it by saying they're
they're based on simple descriptors like
circular fingerprints calculated log PD
PKA a variety machine learning models or
methods that we use the one that's
moving use most frequently would be
random forests for those of you familiar
of those methods all of that is to come
up with a qualitative classifier so
chemist or others designing molecules
can assess the probability
molecule with they're proposing which
have undesirable clearance or plasma
protein binding TBI and so on and we've
achieved a reasonably good results
Houdini's not great the key thing I draw
your attention to in that histogram over
time is after we introduced a human
liver microsomal model the number of
stable molecules on a percentage basis
did go up over time doesn't look like a
huge difference it argue it is a
significant one a lot of molecules made
those are accumulated over 25 to 30
different small molecule projects should
also mention that one of the things that
helped do this with setting
department-wide goals and discovery
chemistry about hitting specific
thresholds with reasonable clearance
criteria it also emphasize these machine
learning models they're not a mechanism
based model they don't offer mechanistic
insight they're pretty much a black box
and they are trained by experimental
data with molecules already in house if
you're working in a brand new series
they're not going to be very useful but
over time is Mormon members of that
series of humilated the models do a
better job at their best they probably
approximate the most experienced
medicinal chemistry valve another one
that's a challenging one to untangle for
project teams is the case where you have
time dependent inhibition of a
cytochrome on a few projects that's been
serious problem for dissolve again
machine learning models have been useful
in a probabilistic way to help
prioritize which molecules were most
likely to get you for anything to go on
the y-axis in this case there's a
calculated probability of having
time-dependent inhibition the x-axis
show
the experimental result for those and
you can see there's a lot of scattered
but what was learned empirically in this
particular project is by keeping keeping
that calculated probability below about
point six you maximize your odds of not
having a serious to the Irish you
another big challenge I think in in
every company I've worked in as the
moderator mentioned I've been a few
places before now almost every project
team here is sigh Billy and obviously if
you can't get a soluble enough molecule
you're never going to be able to dose it
and some projects in early-stage teams
can get misled and chasing an apparent
SAR for say a biochemical assay but if
the molecules are poorly soluble that
SAR you're chasing could easily just be
solubility because not enough of the
molecules getting into solution actually
get a valid biochemical result oh damn
or twine and others in our group did a
lot of work on preparing different
models publisher literature building our
own models and actually found that this
model published several years ago by a
group of GSK well performed better than
anything we've seen not perfect for sure
it's a very simple classifier easy for
people to think about it's simply
healthy number of arithmetic aromatic
rings and some that against calculated
log T at pH 74 so the latter we use
molecular discoveries mocha we find that
works well across a large number of
experimental pk's we have here and also
from roche so this slide is actually
sprayed out of the GSK publication well
that looks pretty good so the green guys
are where you want to be the red ones
are where you for sure you do not want
to be so the next slide dan compare that
with genatech and house I ability data
and pretty astonished to see that it
works just about as well that threshold
weather
it's it's seven on this slide it six on
the previous one is somewhat project in
series dependent we find that it
generalized somewhere between six and
seven and for sure it it's not a
correlation it's simple classifier but
that has helped drive behavior and
design in the right direction to get us
two more soluble molecules to mention
passing we haven't stopped there we have
some work going on in a group to see if
we can come up with some better models
one of those looks pretty promising
still early days so turns out to really
work and stand the test of time but will
for describe that later but for now this
has been a useful model next slide okay
and over time again the results are not
really super dramatic but I draw your
attention to the size of the red area
which are really the brick best
molecules and that has gotten smaller
over time the green has actually gotten
a little bit smaller in the last year
you notice the orange and the yellows
have it have increased and especially
the Reds without and smaller then
there's a lot more work to be done on
improving solubility how we calculated
argue that's one of the most important
and fundamental physical chemical
properties that remains one of the
hardest actually calculate so how do we
pull all this stuff together right these
can be done on spot fire for a variety
of reasons I'm not going to go into now
we chose several years ago to use vortex
well I mentioned one of them general
technique support both Mac and Windows
vortex is one of the few tools that
performs well on both platforms it's
also quite easily scriptable and
programmable so we take a similar
approach here that we took with the
molecular modeling tools hi mo mo behind
the scenes there's a pretty standard
informatics infrastructure that you felt
that's scriptable
each project teams computational chemist
is responsible for maintaining a script
it's custom for their project that pulls
all of the assay dmpk crystallographic
results calculated properties chemical
structures that are relevant for their
project from the corporate database
while into a template and then pushes
that into a vortex session these are
used internally for our project teams we
also share these externally part of our
infrastructure also has to maintain the
ability to support on the order of 250
to 300 x journal chemists that we work
with in several different companies as
collaborators n sierra notice and me
share this SAR data with them through
three vortex actually i'm going to
assume most of you are familiar with
these kind of simple histogram and pie
charts and radar plot analyses the key
point here is I can second subscript
your search this easily similarity
searches we build in some other matched
pair type searches vortex support some
of their own now there's some argue
finalis ease features however I go about
finding them all of fuels anyone that I
select will be highlighted in all these
different views so it's a nice
visualization tool where I can look for
structured property and
structure-activity relationship on
quality shoes the next step then was to
link that to the 3d graphics and here
I've shown doing it in Pinal we've also
done this in MO so that I find some
interesting molecules somewhere my
vortex spreadsheet I can select one as
I've done them will see in the two plots
in the center of the screen their arrows
on the lower plot on one dot which is
one molecule it's highlighted in the
upper graph and vortex and that
molecules coordinates are then sent
through a web service into pinal so
whenever we click on somebody we can
view it 3d immediately of course you
could do that if it's a crystal
structure or if it's a shocking moment
which is just showing sending yet a
third one in there so this was the
beginning of how we started integrating
the 2d chemical informatics and SAR will
do the 3d visualization our goal there
was to realize that thanks to the
advances in structural biology although
it's a much more complicated kind of
data we want to be able to treat crystal
structures like another type of assay
and be able to easily associate from
integrate them with all of the other
assets that that we use to make
decisions there's another recent
innovation that came from Seth Harris a
crystallographer here at Genentech
really clever idea T toys is software he
built to really make his and other
structural biologist workflows and
analysis easier a lot of it has cool
features specific to crystallographers
there's a few things the both of us
there are doing structure based design
that really excited about and let me
show you what that looks like so the
idea here is that a simple way to
classify and interrogate structures
isn't just by sub structure or sequence
searching it's by looking at distances
or they could be angles or pseudo
torrents between different parts of
approaching or poking living complex so
for example some of those distances
highlighted here on the next slide here
in sess simple HTML spreadsheet he's
made it easy to enter a distance as a
pair of albums between in this case and
Adam at the end of the P loop of cable
kinase and to another Adam else for an
approaching is relatively fixed when the
idea there is that as you go from one
crystal structure in the neck
that peel it means of course that
distance will change if I sort on that
column then I can traverse all the
structures that are now visualizing in
Pinal and mo or whatever your favorite
tool is in order and I can see a smooth
motion of that we make it easy easier to
spot or there might be other correlated
motions or perhaps activity or
selectivity differences really simple
approach not too hard to implement you
can also imagine I don't forget an
example here extending that to sort of a
heat map analysis where in the heat map
maybe I'm looking at two different
distances almost a series of many folk
crystal structures and color coding it
based on a potency or selectivity to
some other property and those kind of
analyses then can be can be pulled right
back into the vortex chemical
spreadsheet viewer which has heat maps
and all kinds of other nice graphic
visualization tools well I want to give
you a couple quick sort of computational
design SAR examples this was some work
done a few years ago a project here
where the goal was to come up with
inhibitors to drag one findings that are
selectively vs jac to these two active
sites are almost identical there are
very small changes one of the few is a
difference highlighted here that in Jack
Tunney we've have an aspartate at one
position which is a glutamate inject one
of course the glutamate is one methylene
longer let suggest it to the design team
maybe they could figure out how to
perfect preferentially interact with
that longer glutamate and get a stronger
interaction in jail so that's the
approach nature and after a fair amount
of empirical anti-logging here's where
they round up
turns out that isopropyl alcohol we
bought from about 30 fold selectivity
starting from molecules were about two
and a half a three-fold selected
improving those about 10 folder that got
them to where they needed to be crystal
structure they're showing you a jack one
the glutamate and on the next slide
shows your results of four crystal
structures a nice match pair example
when what's going on that provides an
interpretation unfortunate in this case
it was after the fact from the design
work was done all of crystallography
really wasn't working perfectly yet and
we also didn't have the water analysis
tool so what I'm giving you here is a
retrospective example it's highlighted
how we think about those problems in
other systems today but the key concept
here is pretty simple in Jack one it's
making a direct hydrogen bond from that
isopropyl alcohol to one of the
glutamate oxygens or as in Jack to it's
making it through a bridging water we
then applied Schrodinger's water map and
open eyes schmap calculations to that is
to see what we could learn and
qualitatively they give us similar
results the methods behind each of those
programs are very different they're both
trying to get to the same concept which
is to give us design tools for which
waters are likely to be
thermodynamically unstable and therefore
good candidates to displace or
conversing waters that are likely to be
really tightly bound on approaching and
instead with the better targets to think
up to interactive in this case both of
those tools gave a qualitatively similar
result we use both of them today also a
simpler one that comes out of our oasis
for analyzing waters but we still
haven't come up with a consistent best
practice to recommend one over the other
we use we use them qualitatively to
frame design my pocket
when I give you a quick really nice
fragment-based discovery story we've
done a lot of work in fragment based
approaches here its target that we
worked on a few years ago called napped
this was published enjoyment from last
year it's a really cool thriving based
discovery stories as an incredibly
well-behaved protein high resolution
crystal structures if most proteins
behave this way frightened based
discovery would be that now the rest of
structure based design a whole lot
easier right so the in the dark blue and
yellow vectors in there are a very weak
fragment if about 200 micro molar
modestly in efficiency that's what the
point 36 is superimposed on it with the
light green vectors is a previous co
crystal structure of a more advanced
lead compound shown at the bottom of the
slide here there were a variety of
reasons why the team wanted to replace
part of that group and so this was a
simple really a very simple hybrid
design strategy where you take the
fragment and recognize based on the
coach crystal structures these overlays
pretty pretty easily splice the two
together you can see it worked out
pretty well that new fragment optimized
fragment and food potency a lot it still
has a ways to go to get down to where
the lead is clear the concept work got
them in the right direction there's a
further extension of it adding adding on
some more groups on the right-hand side
an important lesson that came out of
this that's not so unusual in
fragment-based projects a little more
dramatic here than many others program
you is it different small or very
similar small molecules combine
differently in this case they're very
weak they're both about 100 micro molar
KD interview cork 80s when the crystal
structures were obtained for these you
can see that they have really different
binding modes
and in each case the fragment is the
dark blue molecule in the center that's
sold an accessible surface it might be
tempting to look at that and say wow how
am I ever going to get any useful SAR
out of this it's what's bouncing around
in the site by now most of us would
argue think of that as a design
opportunity instead and treat them
really as different scaffolds as opposed
to an analog of each other and recognize
that each offers different factors to
come off the design test each of those
vectors with some simple designs and see
if the molecule stays more or less foot
and that's how we approach
brighton-based discovery in general on
many other targets as well is to say
that you group the scaffold to the
fragments based on their hose ideally
from the crystal structure not just the
2d structure you got one more story I'm
going to summarize which was I thought a
a really nice clean example of the
multivariate property driven design and
structure based design this was on
lactate dehydrogenase oncology target we
worked on here a little while ago from
high-throughput chemical screening this
rather unusual hit came out pretty weak
biochemical potency single-digit
micromolar very strongly nad-dependent
binding crystal structure show that it
interacts with nad what made these
particularly interesting is this complex
behavior tautomers and ionization or you
can see there's a negative charge that
can be localized through a fairly large
system when we saw what the crystal
structure looked like that was really
unusual Wow you see if I can get this
fight booked really good right so we've
got an interaction from that a known
type system
that six membered ring to an arginine
it's a little hard to see where this
other interaction from is coming from
the arginine it's actually coming from
the sulfur then there's another one from
this other oxygen to a histidine then an
addition this is an edge to face
interaction between this aromatic ring
in the inhibitor to that aromatically it
stabilizes that folded conformation all
pretty unusual features with that kind
of a PKA not surprisingly it's pretty
tough to optimize these guys to get into
cells that turned up your big challenge
way the team decided to approach that
was to vary these two groups here
calling x and y in a simple may courage
design we could predict their effect on
PKA i'm going to show you here are the
measurements the biochemical potencies
and experimental emergence measurements
for permeability and platinum protein
binding so that matrix was filled out
that allowed them to prepare all four of
those properties for crystal structures
looking for a number of those guys
binding mode is retained and that let
can converge on the design and that
lower left-hand corner where instead of
the so you still have the sulfur linker
but now in the in the ring you've
replaced the original Adam living with a
nitrogen so I just going to sum up with
everything how about I put these I guess
sort of my pet scientific peas that I
think holds back as it field is
computational chemist and
structure-based design the first item I
put there mostly because of getting
excited by stuff that happened in the
Cambridge database
contest i think it was in 2007 that one
group first started trying success and a
notable prediction of small multiple
crystal structures subsequently many
more groups have had pretty good success
would you pull that a totally solved
problem but it looks like it's going to
get there the reason I got excited about
that is reasoning if you can solve that
you can probably get to the point where
you could actually predict solubility
which of course has to be equilibrium
between the gas phase two water phase
free energy of transfer of a small
molecule and also the free interview of
transfer out of the crystal lattice the
gas phase but we're still quite a ways
from being able to pull that off I hope
the state of the art predicting
solubility isn't this simple equation
the vsj published if there's anybody out
there in that problem i inferred you
keep working on it it is really hard it
also mets been passing even gaining
agreement on what the experimental a
safe of solubility is turns out to be
very different difficult being able to
predict accurate quote crystal
structures is still pretty tough docking
methods energy minimization from
available to crystal structures can
occasionally get to that key that good
but in general it's going to be more
like to to it yeah thanks from MSD most
of us who have tried physics based
approaches to scoring and predicting
potency would argue that you want to do
need high quality instructions have a
fighting chance of getting there we're
still pretty far away from being able to
computational II predict large
ligand-induced conformational changes
ligand-induced is probably a misnomer
we're almost certainly is happening as
proteins are sampling a variety of
metastable lower energy confirmations
the right ligand happens to be present
it can trap one of those meta stable
conformation but our ability to be able
to predict those including what might be
a transient say allosteric site is is
still really poor I'm excited by
we're going out to get you Shaw
Institute and groups that Vijay Ponte
who through different md type methods
can see very large-scale change but
these are huge really long simulations
is it another one that's always kind of
bugged me I've yet to hear a satisfying
answer to is why doesn't it fit any
increase as you add more contacts
between two molecules it's a famous
paper from pnas and 1999 that poses that
question the answer still isn't clear
another one I'd mentioned thinking about
that kinase example between track 1 and
draft two in that case the problem was
mostly solved through first-order
interactions there could be much longer
range ones we should be able to take
advantage of electrostatics is the most
long-range force and intermolecular
interactions there's been remarkably a
little work done by incorporating that
into structure based design there's
Teeter at MIT is published in really
nice papers on an approach like that not
sure that's actually been followed a
whole lot yet and finally if we could
begin to do many of these things I think
we could get to sort of a holy grail of
med chem design which is could I predict
the optimization path from an initial
hit through multiple iterations to get
me to a new and final wrap it up by
saying what we focused on is time
together that structure based design
world 3d models prefer torsion angles
lower key confirmations preferred
interactions with multi parameter
optimization with dmpk parameters
calculated properties and so on show you
how we tie together those models ideally
you want to optimize multiple positions
and parameters together rather than one
at a time sar is seldom additive at
multiple positions if you didn't focus
on what this your time you're likely to
optimize yourself into a local minimum
before you get out we
emphasize hypothesis-driven design so
that every molecule that gets proposed
and synthesized is testing some specific
hypotheses if you've done the design
well you may be able to learn about that
hypothesis even if the design failed to
achieve its desired potency or
solubility or clearance goal structure
base design is now routinely used by all
our medicinal chemists including our
collaborators and many of Skaro chemists
and then finally emphasize something
that it was really important to remember
this was the subject of the entire while
a big part of the subject of the entire
computational chemistry borden
conference a couple years ago blind
predictions are the best test for models
and improving them the literature in our
field of bocking fusarium solani is
mostly full of retrospective predictions
and it's turns out to be a whole lot
harder to predict stuff when you don't
know the answer and then it's important
to remember compare that model whether
it's Bocking or qsar versus a reasonable
null hypothesis that null hypothesis
might be what is your medicinal chemists
predict or for a virtual screening
method that's molecular weight
surprisingly many docking is ultra
spoiling them and then finally I want to
thank all the people this is the group
that that I lead other people from RIT
groups and then key software companies
we've worked with and then I'll conclude
there and this weekend good questions
max going alone
okay yeah thanks every thanks Jeff for a
great talk we're ready to take some
questions so I'm going to start you out
with I thought it was really interesting
where you were talking round 12 slide 20
someplace where you're talking about
looking at the distances between parts
of the protein and the the molecule that
your docking in there were there any
lessons learned in that sort of looking
at those distances you know something
more than just you know you kind of have
to space it out and not have things to
close you know sterically to some of
those pieces that's the question a
couple specific projects that I can't
share the gave some I'd say insights
that are hypotheses far from proven and
selectivity and looking at some
particular emotions that were
qualitatively correlated with
selectivity for one target versus
another so those are the kind of
patterns we're looking for we're still
learning how to do that I think I'm now
project teams have only had the
availability of dozens to maybe hundreds
or more official structures in the last
few years we've just now gotten the
tools to analyze them and look at them
as a whole in place in the last couple
years okay we have a question and I'm
sorry if I butcher this person's name
but we have a question from sneha
mascarenhas who's asking if we'll in
silico work be sufficient to broaden IP
filing around potential bioactives to
protect possible subsequent
interchangeable Xand biosimilars from
being developed
right so I'm pretty certain the answer
to that is no I qualify that by saying
I'm a I'm a chemist and chem informatics
person not a patent attorney however
worked closely with them for years and
one of the key requirements and filing
and getting a patent is reduction to
practice which means you have to have
made the molecule and show an
experimental results and having said
that patents do expand through a lot of
virtual molecules but I've not been part
of any strategies which are aware of
others that have successfully defended
IP of chemical matter that only
virtually design okay I have another
question someone is asking this is a
person from FDA young Moo how do you
validate your predictions much of the
literature on occupational methods tends
to be retrospective reproducing
literature data and any of the company
is doing drug discovery the reason they
employ computational chemists chem
informatics and so on our job is to
hopefully improve the efficiency of how
experiments get done and so all the
stuff I talked about it's all about
rating hypotheses and predictive tools
to influence design so the only way is
prediction or do validate predictions is
by experiment
okay here's a person from the University
of Connecticut asking how can you
distinguish between structure-based drug
design and docking studies done using
molecular dynamics studies not sure I
understand the question um honey it's
not appearing on the screen can you can
you repeat it for me again okay just I
sent it the text over to you Jeff but
basically the question is how can you
distinguish between structure-based drug
design and docking studies done using
molecular dynamics studies okay I look
like sure what the question means but so
forth if this three-part so that's a
structure based design what the way we
would typically approach that is an
iterative design by altering one or more
no no crystal structures example of
swapping a scaffold andy cutter atoms
around closing a ring breaking a ring
dynamics we actually do not use much
except in the context of some free
energy perturbation simulations that
were working on testing to see how
useful they can be in more quantitative
methods for predicting structure
molecular dynamics is an analysis truly
modern I'm neither I nor my phone is to
haul some approaches I've seen used and
including them myself in the past with
md I've been to use that to shake up a
protein ligand crystal structure that
includes an analog we've designed the
test how stable is the local minimum
that molecule is in but md whether it's
done with MVP
your MP BSA or just long dynamic
trajectories is an analysis tools / not
aware of ways to use that in design and
internet docking also not a design tool
if we have a scoring function at any of
us believe in for docking it could be a
design tool I spent a long time working
on that problem before only to conclude
docking is the wrong problem the right
problem is scoring how do you predict
how do you predict the free energy of
binding if you can solve that then
there's a number of docking engines that
we could throw designs at dock them and
then score I hope that sort of answer
the question all right I'm going to ask
one more question this is the last one
someone from chatham university is
asking about different crystal
structures are often obtained with one
protein with a substrate or an inhibitor
bound he wants to know how much does
that play into the predicted ligands
that you get out of your your design
calculations and could you know could
that affect which ones you obtain yeah
for sure ideally we want Co crystal
structures with the most similar ligands
to the ones we're working on in
chemistry so for example an a PO protein
crystal structure often is not very
relevant to abound one the active site
for binding site may open or change its
shape considerably depending on the
ligand that's bound some classes of
proteins are really notorious for that
like nuclear hormone receptors are
incredibly flexible move a lot from one
chemical series to another some others
like serine proteases tend to be better
behaved more rigid the one example
protein I had in there called napped
putting on the rock kinase is are highly
flexible so anyway the short story is
yeah for sure we want the most relevant
ligand we can if we base a all over
kinase inhibitor design on a code
crystal structures say with ATP or ATP
NP we would be severely misled because
of all the flexibility in those systems
that's why over time there's been so
much investment made in protein
engineering on all the other many parts
that drive crystallographic success so
that we can get what are typically soaps
of small molecules bound into protein
crystals fast enough to drive chemistry
and by fast enough and say we want that
turnaround time to be a couple days all
right well as I said that was our last
question that's all the time we have
many thanks to Jeff for a terrific talk
and many thanks to all of you for tuning
in this concludes CNN's second annual
virtual symposium if however you miss
any of the talks earlier in the day let
me remind you that they will be
available on demand of the conference
website for three months after the live
broadcast have a great night Khemka
tears